recrutou se homens para uma jornada
perigosa salários baixos frio extremo
longas horas de escuridão completa
retorno em segurança duvidoso em caso de
sucesso honra e reconhecimento
certa vez ouvi essa frase e eu me
identifiquei bastante com ela é porque
eu tenho como foco a ou não dinheiro por
dinheiro eu tenho uma filosofia
diferente de trabalho
eu busco meu trabalho com honra e
reconhecimento
sei que no no mercado de
empreendedorismo a gente não consegue
fazer nada sem dinheiro mas eu acho que
ele não pode ser o foco
eu sou músico nas horas vagas tem uma
banda que roda o brasil tocando ea gente
vai de carro ou de ônibus vai do jeito
que dá
e raramente a gente recebe por isso
muita gente me pergunta por que vocês
não param não é porque vocês continuam
eu falo não isso realiza eu faço com
paixão então não tem não tem porque eu
parar só porque a gente não recebe o
dinheiro é em se tratando de empresa no
empreendedorismo a gente não consegue
abrir uma empresa sem visar o mínimo de
retorno porque a gente precisa sustentar
o negócio só que a minha filosofia
justamente honra e reconhecimento
foi assim que eu fui atrás do meu irmão
pra gente decidiu a gente fez faculdade
juntos mesma sala
trabalhamos na mesma empresa é pelo
mesmo tempo inclusive e em carreiras
parecidíssimas a gente terminou a
faculdade tinha um objetivo que era de
montar um negócio
e nesse processo todo ele queria montar
uma empresa de videogame porque ele é
viciado e eu queria montar uma de
produção fonográfica já puxando pelo
lado música queria fazer o que eu gosto
e ainda
consegui me manter por isso só que um
demonstrou um projeto de moça
extremamente caro que um retorno bacana
mas não tinha um capital inicial
o estúdio tinha uma rentabilidade uma um
capital inicial tranquilo
só que ele tinha pouca me dava pouca
possibilidade de diferenciação
então é é a gente estava mantendo essas
idéias e meu irmão me convidou e a juiz
de fora que é cara tinha acabado de ser
promovido na empresa ele estava morando
lá e ele me disse que ela fazia muito
frio eu gosto bastante frio
aproveitei foi passar férias só que
quando cheguei lá estava muito quente e
ele me convidou
andar pela cidade para conhecer a cidade
e nesse caminho ele me disse que tinha
duas empresas que seriam modelos para o
nosso projeto e queria me mostrar
só que no meio do caminho que ela estava
grande tinha uma portinha ótima uma
microempresa lá que na fachada tinha
escrito milkshakes ea gente ficou lá
enfrentou uma fila pra gente se
refrescar do calor é e quando o meia o
milkshake eu fui conversando com ele
veio como um tiro assim na minha mente
essa idéia eu falei cara milk shake
igual a calor é igual à goiânia grande
possibilidade da certa ea partir daí
tudo mudou
a gente se comprometeu em fazer um novo
plano de negócios ea gente reestruturou
tudo novamente
a gente é fez fez todos os estudos
relacionados ao produto porque zona
totalmente desconhecida a gente me
motivou bastante por isso ea gente
começou a fazer investigação porque a
gente não sabia como fazer o produto a
gente pesquisou internet
a gente teve a cara-de-pau chegar em
algumas empresas que são similares no
mercado de pedir para entrar na empresa
e deixaram a gente viu como era todo o
layout lá foi atrás de marca de máquina
marca de copo início a gente terminou
concluiu o plano de negócio para a nossa
pra nossa sorte onde negócio deu
positivo é extremamente rentável
daí começou uma outra coisa é o nosso
projeto
a ambição do nosso projeto era como
informei ofereçam serviços
haddad não focando somente o dinheiro
então a gente fez todo um projeto que
deu bastante certo e agente em si ou com
inúmeros diferenciais não todos que a
gente gostaria mas a gente já começou
com um diferencial entre os concorrentes
a gente começou com 53 sabores de milk
shakes e em seis meses já eram 180 em
dois anos a gente abrir nossa primeira
filial e hoje contamos com duas lojas
duas lojas aqui em goiânia e e três
novos produtos do nosso mix
então nós estamos agora com quatro
produtos é o que me deixa bastante
motivado
eu não sou rico mas o dinheiro continua
entrando tranquilamente é a gente está
tendo uma repercussão maravilhosa a os
elogios com o produto eles receberão
todas as nossas expectativas e por que a
gente mais quente mas fica feliz é que a
gente momento algum desvio do foco e
diesel da nossa razão de existir que é
onde o dinheiro ele não tem a o papel
fundamental e que é seguindo nessa
ideologia gente luta para manter o
fornecimento de serviço de melhor
qualidade e que o dinheiro é só uma
consequência do sucesso pra gente ele
veio como honra e reconhecimento
obrigado